Keith Urban's ninth studio album is here
isn't his most personal yet hey I'm
Sylvia lacy welcome to certified country
earlier this week I sat down with Keith
at east-west Studios in Los Angeles
where he opened up about that one nicole
kidman lyric everyone's talking about
congratulations graffiti you is the new
album tell me about the title it means
really personal self-expression is what
making the album was to me we did a lot
of the record here actually we did we
wrote Gemini right in that control room
right over there this is line everyone's
talking about maniac in bed Brainiac in
her head
[Music]
how did Nick react to the first time she
heard it I think she liked it do you
think wasn't it cool here with you when
you wrote it maybe that's why I got so
into missing her maybe but Keith also
recorded much of the album at his home
studio in Nashville with his wife and
daughters by his side the studio that we
built has huge big windows so even on a
gloomy day it's pretty light in there do
your girls pop in yeah occasionally sure
are they interested in what what dad's
doing in there while you're working a
little bit yeah yeah a little bit our
seven year olds picked up the violins a
bit of piano between the two of them
yeah also getting in on the musical
action his wife of nearly 12 years who
sings background vocals on this one
whose idea was that was my idea cuz she
was home and and I thought that's a very
that's a powerful song especially as the
father loved girls as well but that song
quickly got labeled part of the meter
movement and all all of that movement
and there is some element of inspiration
in that song from that but there's only
two lines in the second verse that
pertain specifically to that the entire
rest of the song is the most beautiful
song of want and hope and gratitude from
my perspective from every female in my
life that's in the now and has been
there for my mom it's a very very
powerful song I was really grateful I
got to record it so it was natural for
you to want your wife to be involved is
the perfect song yeah I was so right she
was home and I see you need to come down
if you can and can you sing on there so
she came down I got great footage of her
singing at the mic
she just joined you on stage recently
it was a great moment of I was talking
that parallel line actually the song and
from the back of the room I hear this
voice play this song so she said play
the sense of I suddenly thought well you
come up here and sing it which I never
thought she would I think she'll never
heckle me
that song is permanently stuck in my
head I think no thank you or sorry yeah
no that's a good thing right what is
home to you we've seen a lot of places
it's where it's certainly we're nicking
the girls though we're Hong is is
different for everybody
sometimes it's not even a physical place
and I thought about my early days in
Nashville you know 20 to 6 years ago
when I moved to Nashville and it's
definitely where I want to be you know
it's a great town city of my dreams and
all that but it was hot it was really it
was a hard town to break into especially
coming from another country and when it
got really hard
I was really envious those people who
could get in that car and drive back to
Georgia no tribe back to Canada even you
know I couldn't just get my car and
drive home so a lot of the spirit of all
of those things came into play in the
south the country crooner is getting
ready to hit the road again soon he told
us the couple's two daughters
seven-year-old faith and nine-year-old
Sunday loved being out on the tour bus
with them let's talk about the tour what
can we expect this time around a damn
good time yeah I mean we're weird tons
of new songs off graffiti you which I
was so built for playing live we've done
a few little shows in the last week with
a stagecoach and a few little other club
shows and things and already playing
these songs live just like a blast yeah
yeah so getting them into the
amphitheater this is gonna be so fun
what about the production what does that
like it's just me and a guitar and a
candle super cheap yeah I'd done the
whole thing in an uber just snow trucks
nothing just raking it in it's the news
the new thing is like no production um
just come see it yeah come and see it
it'll be it'll be a blast
from one thing Keith's not keeping mum
about his thoughts on the newly rebooted
American Idol have you been watching
with Katie Lionel no yes what do you
think I'll tell you what I love is
Lionel's feedback he's he's so he's so
built for that he's such a good
he's like a coach like a mentor coach
he's got good advice he delivers it
really well really good were you ever
asked to come back I think the show was
going in a lot of you know trying to
figure out what to do where to go what
sort of things so did any of them ask
you for advice like Luke maybe not
advice I mean I still look for he did it
and he was asking what's it gonna be
like I said you gonna have a blast it's
a fun show the graffiti you tour kicks
off this summer with Kelsea Ballerini
thank you for watching and hit the
comments to let me know what you think
of Keith's new album drop top and horses
are two of my favorite tracks but I want
to hear about your be sure to subscribe
to Entertainment Tonight on YouTube for
new episodes of certified country every
Friday we'll see you next week
you